a new segment tonight with one of our
favorite guests Congressman Steve
Scalise all right congressman we're
tentatively calling this the new zwip
with a Minority Whip it's really cheesy
but let's try it out I want to begin
with this the president hosting a number
of Democrats at the White House today
for negotiations on infrastructure here
was just some of the reaction from both
parties you want to spend money I want
to spend money you want to build bridges
I want spend how do you feel about that
as a Democrat the ball is now in his
court will he be able to deliver well in
the past
he often hasn't there's work we need to
do on our roads and our bridges the
committee has been working on that in a
bipartisan way very excited about the
conversation that we had with the
president it's about jobs jobs jobs they
were all smiley and they were so happy
coming out of that meeting so you know
why was Nancy so giddy I guess
Republicans and Democrats are gonna blow
two trillion on interest and of course
if you're Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
it's taxes taxes taxes and that's where
they're gonna want to go it's got to be
paid for and without new taxes and
that's where I think it probably breaks
down look at Nancy now that was today
look at her smiles versus during the
immigration meeting she was biting her
lip on the on the right look how happy
that's a tale of two Nancy's what's
going on here I mean what is Trump doing
the charm offensive buddy I guess they
started at 1 trillion he's like well
let's just do two trillion what is that
I think there's a lot of money well we
are 22 trillion dollars in debt
congressman there can be no deficit
spending and no new taxes and again
that's where I think it breaks down
I think she's smiling just because she
got to get away from the Capitol and all
of the Socialists and aoc and Omar and
to leave that have just bogged hard down
in this mire of you know the
anti-semitism socialism the Boston
Marathon bomber voting Laura that's
where that morality the Joe said he's
gonna be the morality sleep around
make America moral again that's Joe
Biden's new pitch to the voters all
right congressman some think that the
president is looking for an
infrastructure for immigration trade so
we'll give you infrastructure you got to
give us some some stuff on immigration
enforcement but a new poll reveals that
the
centage of democrats who see the border
as a crisis
jumped 17 points since January amid the
spike in migrant families so if Democrat
voters are coming to this conclusion
finally that this is a real emergency
why would the president have to
negotiate here well you know maybe the
infrastructure is the wall and again
people get that we need to secure the
border people Republicans and Democrats
agree we ought to secure the border
you know how exactly do you do it they
recognize you're gonna have to have some
physical barriers most I'm not talking
about Washington Democrats I'm talking
about people when you go out into the
mainland of this country they want a
secure border and they know the crime
that's coming across they know the drugs
that are be brought across they see this
caravan and the caravan Washington might
yet the multiple caravans with you know
all of the the problems that it's
bringing and all these interior problems
catch and release the lunacy of this
infrastructure is never odd man how did
it
how did five G become an infrastructure
we thought it was like shovel ready all
right we got it one more thing we got to
mention Bernie Sanders you mentioned
moments ago that he's tripling down on
this fight to restore the rights of
felons to vote but it doesn't just go
there let's watch at a time when the
Republican Party and Donald Trump are
working overtime to suppress the vote to
make it harder for people of color we
have got to make it clear in my view
that if you are an American citizen even
if you do something terrible we cannot
take away your right to vote whether
you're in jail or whether you left jail
clearly what Republicans are doing is
trying to deny people of color the right
to vote that's it death row inmates for
Bernie that's the most offensive thing
and nobody's trying to take when
President Trump of all people he's been
celebrating the fact that
african-american unemployment it's at
the lowest in the history and Bernie
won't celebrate that but then he wants
to give felons in in prison the right to
vote while they're in prison we're for
everybody being able to vote one time in
each election and they're having
problems with those kind of laws that
make sure that you have the integrity
the vote for everybody
protect everybody's right to vote except
felons if you're in federal prison you
shouldn't be vote do you know Biden at
all I mean do you know yeah minimum
number times do you think he's missed if
he's missing knew he's dropping words
he seems like he doesn't seem like the
old James Oh like a little few steps go
look if you had to compete in this field
of socialists it's it's a different
world out there than when he started in
politics that's for sure congressman
thank you so much always with you more
as always are